a magical dragon blade humanoid villains
controlled by namari and a much darker
ending for sisu are just some of the
fascinating scenes and storylines disney
cut from raya and the last dragon
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing and explaining all
the deleted scenes from disney's writer
you never got to see
we will of course be talking spoilers so
take care
before the dream became the faceless
swirling mists of purple that we see in
the final film the villains were going
to be very very different much more
humanoid monsters a bit like
armored giants in fact and there's a
great deleted scene with these alternate
versions of the drone that would have
appeared at the beginning of the movie
in a chapter called
tale of the dragon for years we've been
on our own broken
losing hope with no one to protect us
from the drone
i don't have it
no one but me
in this story raya was a mysterious
warrior known as dragonblade and her
sword had a dragon pendant from her
father benja
dragon blade because these villains had
a specific form they could be fought in
a more conventional manner than the more
ethereal drone we see in the final movie
ordinary weapons were still
ineffective against them though and only
ryan's magical sword dragonblade which
he created herself could defeat these
sentient villains
ryan's weapon had the ability to pierce
their armor and then a clicking device
caused them to melt while green goo
exploded from their bodies what are you
doing here i'm helping you
no i don't need your help look out you
need one of these
to do this
as an extra twist these dream were
originally controlled by namari who in
early versions of the movie was more of
a traditional disney villain in the vein
of maleficent or cruella de vil
the deleted scene goes on to show how
raya has to improvise against the drone
when she keeps on losing her sword and i
especially like how she uses the bell
against them
the scene also introduces tuk-tuk as
rya's trusted and crucial sidekick who
in a change from the final film she
didn't meet when he was a baby but who
helps her out of her sticky situation
when she's cornered by the drone
which is intentionally amusing given her
earlier comment to the villager who
wants to help her fight
i'm sorry i have to do this alone
i don't need a sidekick and that deleted
line of course highlights raya's
evolution over the course of the film
from a lone fighter to someone willing
to work with others
these humanoid droon also appear in
another deleted scene where rya rescues
a group of kumondrans fighting each
other on a bridge from a drone who's
about to attack them
move your wagon no you move your wagon i
was here first hey here's an idea how
about you move your wagon
[Music]
grandma grandma hurry come on we gotta
go
we can also see from this cut scene that
these early versions of the drone turn
objects to stone by grabbing hold of
them as we see the monster try to do to
rya's sword
and of course that's something the
drones do to humans in the final film
not this sword as we can see
raya's original sword was magical and
resistant to the drone's powers
and like her sword in the final film
this sword also had the ability to
extend an attack from afar with a
grappling hook
now despite their human-like form these
drone was still very resilient with the
ability to regenerate limbs even after
ryan breaks them off
another interesting detail from this
deleted scene is that it looks like
rather than meeting the angie's and
talon as she does in the final movie
raya would have met them at this point
in her journey as we see the hilariously
mischievous monkeys stealing the fruit
the two commanders are throwing at each
other
move your wagon move your wagon
in the end disney decided to abandon the
human light take on the drone in favor
of making the villains more of an
amorphous
faceless evil their connection to namari
was also dropped
in favor of making raya's human
antagonist more nuanced and developing
her relationship with raya instead
i can also see that as cool as a magical
sword would have been
dropping that idea fits in better with
the final movie's theme of raya having
to cooperate with others and trust in
them in order to save the day
and a deleted flashback to ryan's
childhood shows how the original movie's
main theme was centered on the notion of
how hope can inspire community
this is the heart of the dragon a rare
and very special flower
like the dragon it's connected to water
watch
[Music]
and look each flower responds to the
light of the other
one flower made all those light up yes
one light can light a thousand more
that's what the dragons did
they inspired light and hope in all the
people around them
i wish the whole world could see this
maybe one day you'll show them although
this is a sweet scene
i wonder whether the implication that
raya would be inspired to fix the world
by the heart of the dragon could have
felt too reminiscent of moana who used
the heart of te fiti to restore peace to
her world
the heart of te fiti was the green gem
the ocean gave to moana who then lifted
the curse threatening her island when
she returned the stone to the lava demon
to carr
given there were already a number of
similarities between the two movies such
as shape-shifting deuteragonists
the importance of water and a faceless
threat to the land the heart of the
dragon concept
could have made the comparisons with
moana a few too many
some fans of the movie have pointed out
the romantic tension between raya and
namari in several scenes
hey there princess undercut and raya's
voice actress kelly marie tran has said
that's also how she interpreted it
though she added that wasn't the
official disney line
and there seems to be a little more of
that freeson in an alternate version of
the scene when raya meets the grown up
namari for the first time
oh what's trippin doodra oh i see you
finally made some friends
it's good that you're reaching out so
what are you up to
you stole an ancient map and scrolls
from the royal library correction
i was just borrowing them indefinitely
in the final film this encounter takes
place in the tale
temple where sisu and raya find the
second piece of the dragon gem whereas
in the deleted scene it appears to take
place in the shipwreck with sisu donning
a disguise rather than shape-shifting
into human form
why are you making me wear this i'm
doing this to protect you
from who from everyone we have to sneak
into
five different hostile nations in my day
there were no nations kumandra was one
large happy numari and in contrast the
more indiana jones style escape out of
the cave we see in the final film
in this alternate version raya uses a
trick from tuk-tuk to clear a path
through nemari's soldiers
dinner time what
it's like three o'clock in the afternoon
why would you yell dinner
come on during the alternate chase scene
riot and sisu also stopped to recover a
dragon gem piece at the bottom of a well
i sense a gem piece
there mariah spills a catch of fish to
distract namari's big cats so she can go
and collect the stone
oh what the [ __ ] are you doing there
that well
um raya catch
[Music]
haha shape change power it's back
although this looks like a fun scene it
seems to over
complicate the getaway from namari and
also kind of crams in the shape-shifting
power reveal
giving it less importance so i can see
why it was changed
in the final movie after ryan and sisu
escape from namari they end up on the
shrimporium a boat restaurant run by
boone
welcome to the world famous shrimp oreo
my name is boone i'll be your server
today would you like to hear our daily
specials
yes please however in an earlier version
of the movie
boone was a mr fix-it character who
owned a scrap yard and ryan met him
before she even met sisu when she was
looking for someone to fix a crack on
tuk-tuk's plate
after a piece of drone arm got stuck
inside
that mean i can get things fixed here
depends what needs fixing it's my pill
bear here he's got a crack
who doesn't that came out wrong in this
deleted version of the story we also
discover that boone is secretly hoping
to team up with the legendary
dragonblade warrior to defeat namari
nice target setup not a lot of hits but
is that amari
hey nothing to see here it's part of a
secret mission i'm working on if you
have to know
i'm teaming up with dragonblade to take
down omari and the drew dragonblade
yeah dragonblade defender of the five
lands
slays droon with his deadly sword it has
a dragon pendant swinging off of it
nope can't say i've heard of him as
often happens in animation and as we've
seen with many disney movies including
zootopia frozen and moana the studio
often drastically shifts and changes
storylines even relatively late in a
movie's production
and at one point ryan's filmmakers
seriously considered a much darker
bittersweet ending for the movie
disney always planned to have sisu die
so that raya would come to understand
that she couldn't just rely on a magical
dragon to save kumandra
however in an alternate ending cece
would have remained dead so she wouldn't
have been resurrected even after the
rain fell
and banished the drone in that ending
none of the dragons were resurrected
making sisu quite literally
the last dragon that might have been
more striking because it would have
solidified the sacrifice the dragons
made for kumandra and made the impact of
human discord more long
lasting but the filmmakers wanted to go
with a happy ending so they resurrected
sisu together with all the other dragons
to create in their words a big disney
moment that makes your heart sing
and if you want to learn about more
amazing alternate endings and deleted
scenes for animated movies such as the
deleted mecca furby from the mitchells
vs machines or how elsa nearly died in
frozen 2 then tap here to check out my
full playlist
now do you wish any of these deleted
scenes have been included in the movie
let me know in the comments below don't
forget to like and subscribe if you
enjoyed this video
and tap left to discover more disney
deleted scenes or tap right for
something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers